The Definition of Gossiping.
Gossiping appears to be part of human nature.
There are sociologists, linguists, psychologists, and historians...
...who actually research gossip and how it functions in society.
It's a tricky phenomenon to study, though.
People usually gossip spontaneously and in private,...
...so it's undisputable that it's almost impossible to study gossip in a laboratory setting.
In fact, many researchers study gossip by eavesdropping on gossipers.
When researchers study gossip, they don't all use the same definition.
Most start with the same basic idea:...
...gossip is a conversation between two people that concerns a third person who is not present.
Different researchers then add a range of stipulations,...
...even if others might not agree with them.
For example, one addition would be that the people talking are transmitting information as though it was fact,...
...but they have not confirmed the information as factual.
As far as I'm concerned, regardless of how you define it,...
...gossip is wrong whether fact or fiction!